[Music]
the new school year is right around the
corner and a lot of families are still
scrambling to get their kids ready for
class on monday
local leaders are stepping in to help
with the special back to school fair and
it's happening right now
sasha loftis is live there tonight with
more
denise we are about an hour into this
back to school fair and
it is nonstop there are just dozens of
people filing in
looking to take advantage of this
opportunity to make that back to school
process
a little smoother that today's fair
again started about an hour ago at four
o'clock
county commissioner william mccurdy is
giving out 2
000 free backpacks they're going fast
but there are still
some left it appears there's also free
dental and vision screenings available
along with covet 19 vaccines for anyone
12 and older
30 other local organizations are also
taking part in addition to clark county
that includes metro police and anthem
blue cross blue shield
organizers tell us this is just really a
great way to get our community kids
ready for class
and keep them healthy it is very
important here
on this side of district d on the east
side of district b we have a pretty
transient neighborhood
we have people that are in need of help
you can see all of the kids and we want
to get them back to school
ready for school on that first day of
school and very well prepared
now remember supplies are available as
they last they are limited of course so
if you want to come down and take
advantage of this opportunity
i would do so as quickly as possible but
back out here live
there is about another two hours left
for this event it wraps up
around seven o'clock tonight it's here
at walnut recreation center
that's near las vegas boulevard and
cheyenne in the north valley reporting
live tonight sasha loftis
8 news now